ich verstehe das gar nicht du hattest
mir doch erzählt dass nur eine von euch
den freien platz haben könnten ja das
stimmt eigentlich auch aber dann ist
noch eine abgesprungen und dann gab es
noch kein platz mehr
super herzlichen glückwunsch ich freue
mich für euch für mich auch ich finde
ich ziemlich nett danke das kann ich nur
zurückgeben aber das recht ich finde es
wichtig dass wir uns gemeinsam hinsetzen
und den stundenplan machen
ich habe das vorlesungsverzeichnis
überhaupt nicht verstanden
das finde ich auch schwierig aber
immerhin haben wir ein seminar
zusammengelegt der rest wird sich finden
müssen wir hier eigentlich eine
hausarbeit schreiben oder eine klausuren
ja aber erst am ende des semesters bis
dahin wir noch zeit viel wichtiger dass
wir gemeinsam ist unternehmen
ciao alex und ich wollten in die mensa
kommst du mit ja sehr gerne wartet ihr
noch einen moment ich komme sofort
lena ich muss jetzt auf legen wir wollen
los war die uni ist so toll ich habe
mich sofort mit zwei kommilitonen
angefreundet
alex du weißt doch noch diese gut
aussehender typ vom falafel laden ja der
ist echt total nett hat mir angeboten
mit ihm zu lernen zu pauken aber bist du
dir sicher dass er nur mit dir pauken
will ich hab doch noch ben hat er sich
dann wieder bei dir gemeldet nein er ist
ja auch unterwegs
er war tatsächlich an falsche bahn
aufgaben du nur deinen traum prinz du
denkst du lang gar nichts anderes
mehreren meldest dich überhaupt nicht
mehr
wir haben uns schon ewig nicht gesehen
das tut mir leid die unis so stressig
und ich hab verloren
und heute nachmittag auch eigentlich
habe ich uni aber karl hat vorgeschlagen
dass wir blau machen und ins kino gehen
ich sehe mir mit ihren neuen film mit
george clooney an
auch carla ist wirklich total müsste sie
mal kennenlernen
dann hab viel spaß mit einer neuen
freundin
carla